die zweite corona welle ist voll in
frankreich angekommen
zuletzt gab es täglich 32.000 neue fälle
die kurve zeigt steil nach oben ab 21
uhr wird paris nun zur geisterstadt im
partyviertel rund ums berühmte moulin
rouge sind in der dunkelheit fast nur
noch lieferanten mit ausnahmegenehmigung
und wohnungslose kloss unterwegs kneipen
die an einem samstagabend eigentlich von
menschen wimmelnden alex in paris geht
seit samstag eine corona sperrstunde
zwischen 21 und 6 uhr müssen alle leben
zu haben und hier wird sich auch daran
gehalten hinter mir ist das weltberühmte
im moulin rouge es zu wie alle bars in
dieser straße hier zb samstagabend hier
werden normalerweise alles voll von
party leuten und die paar menschen die
hier noch unterwegs sind müssen jetzt
mit einer strafe von 135 euro rechnen
hin und wieder fahren polizeistreifen
die boulevards entlang und fordern die
letzten streunenden per lautsprecher auf
nach hause zu gehen
das mit dem virus nicht zu spaßen ist
erzählt der junge franzose adrian er
hatte sich im märz infiziert hat
überlebt bis heute leidet der einst
begeisterte sportler unter atemproblemen
früher konnte ich eine stunde lang in
zwölf kilometer die stunde
jetzt schaffe ich noch 15 minuten mit 8
kilometern die stunde
mein herz schlägt 180 mal die minute
anders als im frühjahr will frankreichs
staatspräsident emanuel makro dieses mal
einen kompletten locker und verhindern
um die wirtschaft zu retten
die besonders betroffenen bar und
restaurantbesitzer machen nach
berechnungen nur 2,2 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes aus schon jetzt
ist klar dass in frankreich im zweiten
quartal 2020 das bruttoinlandsprodukt um
13,6 prozent gesunken ist
wir sind bild und wir liefern
die news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren